я хочу сказати пану данілову який вчора
там виступив що в перемогу треба вірити
Так в перемогу треба вірити і Ми віримо
в перемогу але на перемогу треба ще
працювати працювати кожен день ні
серіали Ні барабани працювати на
перемогу зброя армія ще раз зброя армія
фордифікації це називається працювати на
перемогу ми зараз продовжимо період
загальної ілізації А де чесна відповідь
тим хто вже 20 місяців мобілізований
скільки вони будуть служити Як так може
бути що вхід є а виходу Немає чому немає
ніякого терміну скільки вони відслужили
і зможуть після того щоб їх замінили
інші не можна витягти війну на плечах
одних тих самих людей